[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMIR HAMMOUDI: Hi, everyone.
My name is Samir.
I'm a gaming solution
architect at Google Cloud.
Today I will be introducing you
to Open Match, an open source
matchmaking framework
based on Kubernetes.
Then Ishikawa-san from Grenge
will share about the experience
using Open Match
in "Kick-Flight,"
a new 4v4 mobile game that
just released last month.
So before diving in to Grenge's
experience of Open Match,
let's first take a look
at what exactly it is.
But to explain to you
how it was founded,
I first need to explain the
challenges that many developers
face with matchmaking services.
Matchmaking is one of the
hardest unsolved problems
for online multiplayer games.
At a fundamental level,
matchmaking takes players,
connect to your games, to
match them up and connect them
to game servers.
Creating a good match is
critical to your game's
success.
And what constitutes a good
match changes from game
to game.
You have to consider attributes
like skills, level, latency,
wait time.
And they are all
critical to your game.
In general, making a good
matchmaking service for a game
is hard, but it's core
to your game design.
Running this as a global scale
for your player population
presents a whole different
set of challenges.
Architecting a
matchmaking service
that can run at high skill,
reliably, is very hard,
and may not be an
interesting problem
to solve for a game developer.
This is exactly why
Open Match was created.
So Open Match is an open
source matchmaking framework
co-founded with Unity.
It leverages Kubernetes
to provide flexibility,
scalability, and extensibility.
Just to give you an example
of scale it can handle,
maybe you remember the
Halloween Doodle from 2018,
that 4v4 multiplayer game you
could play from the Google.com
website.
Yeah, that one was using
Open Match to match players.
And it handled a concurrent
peak of 500,000 players.
Because, with Open
Match, you don't
need to worry about the
scalability and reliability
of the underlying
infrastructure,
you can focus on building the
core logic of your matchmaker.
Because I think a picture
is worth a thousand words,
let's take a look at the
high-level architecture
of how online games will
integrate with Open Match.
On the left side, you
have a game front end
with your core game logic.
That calls into the
matchmaking framework.
And at the same time,
on the right side,
you have a pool of
servers that players
can be placed on that's
simultaneously calling
in the matchmaking logic.
Open Match sits in the middle,
handling the players that
are available, splitting
them by skill level, latency,
et cetera, and match
them up with servers
that are available.
As a developer, you only care
about developing the match
function, which contains the
core logic of your matchmaker.
The left and right boxes
are component from your game
that you need to
integrate with Open Match.
Let's take a closer
look at those components
in the left and right boxes.
The game front end is the
endpoint where your game
clans will connect to.
To avoid cheating, you
don't want them to directly
connect to the Open
Match front end,
because only your game front
end is capable of verifying
the data provided
by the game clans
by accessing a database
containing player's data.
So basically it's your
game front end that
creates matchmaking requests--
also called tickets--
in Open Match.
On the right side, you find
the game back end-- also
called director-- and the
dedicated game servers.
Your game back end is a key
component in the matchmaker
since it triggers the
match function execution.
Once Open Match
finds matches, it
will also handle the
assignment of game service
to the match players.
This architecture is
something you can then
reuse across your games as
you build multiple games.
To have a better idea of
how is the flow of a match,
let's take a look at the
life of a match step by step.
First step, a player wants to
play against other players.
The game clan makes a request
to your game front end
to find a match.
It's the game front
end that actually
makes the request to
the Open Match front end
to find a match.
Every request are stored in the
state store running on Redis.
As I mentioned in
the previous slide,
it's the game back end that
triggers the match function
using the Open Match back end.
The game back end
requests for a match.
The Open Match back triggers
the matchmaking function
that uses the query component
to create Redis and find
candidates for a match.
Once a match is found,
the Open Match back end
will return it to the game
back in that will then
finalize the entire matchmaking
process by assigning
a dedicated game server
to the match players.
The last step of the life of
a match is the assignment.
It's the last step
where we assign a game
server to the matched players.
For this, the game back end,
we allocate a dedicated game
server by using solutions like
Agones or any other custom
server management system.
Once it gets the allocated
game server IP and port,
it will reach out again
to the Open Match back end
to update the tickets
stored in the state store
with that information.
Finally, once tickets
have been updated,
the game front end will push
that game server details
to players, who will then
connect to the server and just
start to play.
And, voila, that's how Open
Match works in a nutshell.
Hope this was clear enough.
If you're building
a small game, you
might not be interested in
a complex, highly-scalable
matchmaking framework.
But you can still
leverage Open Match
to write a simple
matchmaking function that
will look like a single function
in the language of your choice.
Plug that into the
framework, and you'll
have a fully functional
matchmaking service
without a lot of work.
But where Open
Match really shines
is if you have a really
large system with thousands
or millions of players that are
all coming at the same time.
And the player population is
segmented into different groups
and matched up very quickly.
So you might be running
hundreds of concurrent matches
on the player population,
looking for the best match
to make your game work.
So now that you know
what Open Match is,
let's listen to the experience
of the Japanese game studio
Grenge using Open Match in
their latest mobile game,
"Kick-Flight."
YASUNORI ISHIKAWA: Hi,
my name is Yasunori.
I'm an engineering
manager at Grenge.
Here to talk about why
and how we use Open Match
in "Kick-Flight."
Our experience is a game
called "Kick-Flight."
"Kick-Flight" is a free-flying
and midair battle action game
for smartphones.
Four-versus-four real-time
multiplayer game.
You control a character
called a kicker.
12 characters with
three game modes.
Available in more
than 130 countries.
Launched on February 13, 2020.
[ROCK MUSIC]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
Here are "Kick-Flight"'s
matchmaking requirements.
The video on the left shows the
matchmaking using Open Match.
Using the kicker
under Game Mode,
and by tapping the Battle
button, matchmakings begin.
"Kick-Flight" will match
two teams of four with
the following requirements--
match users with
similar play skills.
Matching users with far
different play skills
will result in a
one-sided match.
Minimize character
overlaps in battles.
Each of the
characters has a role.
There are four types--
attack, support,
tank, and speed.
Matchmaking is done so that the
same character or role does not
suffer as much as possible.
You can cancel any time
before matchmaking is found.
The progress is displayed in
real time during matchmaking.
There is four reasons why we
decided to use Open Match.
The first one is
because we wanted
to make a general-purpose
matchmaking framework,
because building a matchmaker
for each game is pricey.
Building a general-purpose
matchmaking
with a budget of a
game is not possible.
As a result, each game has
a different matchmaking
implementation, depending
on the type of matchmaking.
Making a matchmaker
game with one game app
can take anywhere from
six months to a year.
Even in that case, there are
many problems about scaling.
In "Kick-Flight", the
development of matchmaking
logic was about
one or two months.
And it took about one month for
version updates and load tests.
Most importantly,
this knowledge can
be used to build faster using
Open Match in the future.
Secondly, because we wanted to
focus on the matchmaking logic,
in general, scalability is a
major issue in matchmaking.
This problem was minimized
because Open Match
is, by design, scalable.
Third, because we could
find working MM examples.
At that time, there
wasn't much documentation,
but there were some
working examples.
We did the source code, and
got the help of Googlers.
The last one is because Open
Match was used successfully
in the Halloween Doodle in 2018.
This is "Kick-Flight"
architecture.
Except for Realtime Game Server,
everything is built on GCP.
The central part is Open Match.
Creation and the
addition of tickets
are performed from
the API Server
through Cloud Load Balancer.
A creation of
assignment is requested
to Open Match via
Ingress and Endpoints.
So therefore, Open Match
uses various parts on GKE.
We have changed that
to Cloud Memorystore.
As a side note, we used Cloud
Spanner as our main database.
In "Kick-Flight," there
are three main components.
The API changes the kicker
and enhances the skill
of a character, called a disc.
It is implemented using PHP7,
and it uses Cloud Memorystore
for Redis for session cache and
Cloud Spanner for player data.
Open Match's version
is version 0.7,
with some customization added.
It handles players matchmaking,
and matchmaking function
is also implemented in PHP7.
Dedicated game server
handles the real-time aspect
of battles.
Let me show you what went
well with Open Match.
We are able to focus on the
development of the matchmaking
logic.
Open Match does the
communication part
with the client and the scale.
So we are able to concentrate on
the matchmaking logic, scaling
the system based on
the number of players.
We can scale by increasing
front end and the matchmaking
function.
Also easily modify the
matchmaking criteria.
Since front end and match
function are separated,
just modify the logic.
Then build and
deploy the images.
We can deploy
without any downtime.
The server management
was simplified,
thanks to the managed services
like GKE and the Cloud
Memorystore.
We used Cloud Endpoints
to secure the access
to the Open Match front end.
It was very easy to use
with GKE, because it
was made for Kubernetes.
By default, Redis
in GKE is used.
But management is easier
using crowd Memorystore.
This helped reduce
operation cost.
Assignment communication is
done via Cloud Endpoints.
Originally, it should be done
via our game server front end.
But handling streaming
connection in PHP is complex.
So we used Ingress and Cloud
Endpoints to handle this part.
Finally, for
monitoring, Open Match
telemetry worked seamlessly
with Stackdriver.
Here are a few changes
we faced with our game.
We launched our game using
Open Match for the first time
in the world.
We used very early
versions, from version 0.3,
of Open Match.
Back in version 0.3, there
was not much documentation.
So we read source codes
with help from Googlers.
Here is some tuning we have
done on Open Match from
"Kick-Flight."
Parallel processing
by splitting profile.
A match profile is Open
Match's representation
of a match specification.
For example,
processing is performed
in parallel for each game mode.
We adjusted the retry intervals.
If the retry interval
is too short,
the load on the Redis
server will increase.
Increasing this interval
can reduce the load
on the Redis server.
We also adjusted the Redis TTLs.
Longer TTL will
increase data volume.
The shorter the TTL, the lower
the load on the Redis server.
We use C2 instances.
It is important to match
in a short period of time,
as it will not be able to
judge if the matchmaking
queue accumulates.
For that purpose,
very fast processing
is realized using C2 instances.
For example, the difference
between 1.0 seconds
and 0.8 seconds will
make a big difference.
We reduced the filter
condition of profile.
The load on increased
according to the multiplication
of the learning
profile and filter.
So we changed to minimum
filter conditions.
We back-ported from version 0.8
because execution from back end
to function was not balanced.
In addition, we performed load
test of communication path
using Locust.
Finally, let's look
back at the game launch.
We are able to handle the
load at the time of launch
flawlessly.
During our load
test, we measured
Open Match could handle at
least 250 entries per second.
We had no incident caused
by Open Match so far.
We developed our own solution
to increasing Redis data.
Open Match version 0.10
will include this fix.
In conclusion, we are very
satisfied with Open Match.
We could accelerate the
game development speed,
and we could provide a very
fast yet scalable matchmaking
service to our players.
We plan to use Open Match
much for our next games
and even expand it to other
game studios in our group.
Lastly, if you are
interested in Open Match,
I recommend looking at the
website, openmatch.dev,
where you can find great
documentation and many examples
to get started with.
I can't wait to see what you
can come up with with Open
Match in your game.
[MUSIC PLAYING]